Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Aya Magdy
Espero que después de tantas charlas impactantes,
poder convencerlos de que lo que tengo que decirles también es importante.
Hace diez años, tuve culebrilla.
¿Alguno de ustedes tuvo culebrilla?
¿Todos saben qué es?
Es una enfermedad viral; en realidad es una forma de la varicela
que te puede agarrar cuando sos adulto, y que toma los nervios.
Y quien la haya tenido, por ahí
sabe: a) que es muy dolorosa,
y b) que todo el mundo parece estar de acuerdo en que
la forma de librarse de ella es yendo a un curandero.
Cuando yo tuve culebrilla, entonces, aproveché para hablar
con la gente que estaba a mi alrededor y que me daba consejos todo el tiempo,
Y decirles: ¿cómo sabés que el tratamiento curanderil funciona?
Y la respuesta, básicamente, tenía siempre esta forma, decían:
"Bueno a mi cuñado, le agarró/tenía culebrilla por todo el cuerpo...
...creíamos que se iba a morir, y fue un curandero,
y en dos días, ¡estaba como nuevo! ¡Al Pelo! No le pasaba nada..."
Y bueno, por más que uno quiera mucho a su cuñado, digamos,
es fácil ver que hay ciertos problemas con este razonamiento.
El principal principal es que a uno le queda la duda de qué le habría pasado
a nuestro cuñado, si no iba al curandero.
Capaz que se curaba igual.
Entonces, ¿cómo hace la ciencia médica para determinar si un tratamiento es eficaz?
Ya sea la cura curanderil de la culebrilla, ó la penicilina.
Y básicamente, se hace lo siguiente:
se toma a un grupo de gente grande, digamos 100 personas,
y que tengan culebrilla y se los hace ir al curandero
Y se toma otro grupo de personas equivalente al primero, otras cien personas
que también tengan culebrilla,
pero que no vayan al curandero.
Y la clave para decidir si el tratamiento es eficaz,
consiste justamente en comparar estos dos grupos.
La gente que va al curandero, ¿se cura más rápido
o en mayor frecuencia que la gente que no va al curandero?
Y el grupo éste, que no se somete al tratamiento,
recibe el nombre técnico de "Grupo Control".
Y es muy importante para arribar a una conclusión correcta.
Lo que yo detecté, hablando con las personas que me rodeaban cuando yo tenía culebrilla,
era que el concepto mismo de "Grupo Control"
parecía estar ausente de sus cabezas, de sus mentes.
Y esto es un ejemplo de un fenómeno mucho más universal,
que es que hay ciertas formas del pensamiento
que son características del pensamiento científico,
que son absolutamente esenciales para arribar a una conclusión correcta,
y que están ausentes de la mente de la mayoría de las personas.
Y esto se debe a dos razones.
Una es que estas formas de pensamiento no aparecen espontáneamente en la gente.
A "pensar científicamente", te tienen que enseñar.
Y la otra razón es, por supuesto, que el sistema educativo
no está en condiciones de enseñarle a pensar científicamente a la mayor parte de la gente.
Y lo que yo quería contarles esta tarde es una iniciativa
de un grupo de científicos y educadores, justamente, para atacar este problema.
Para desarrollar estrategias que nos permitan enseñarle a la mayor cantidad de gente posible,
cómo pensar científicamente.
La iniciativa se llama "Expedición Ciencia",
es una organización sin fines de lucro,
y nuestro laboratorio, donde nosotros desarrollamos y ponemos a prueba nuestras ideas,
es un campamento.
Un campamento que reúne todos los años, por 10 días,
a 50 chicos de todas las provincias de la Argentina
con un grupo de científicos.
Es decir, de personas con experiencia en investigación.
Y a mí, lo que me gustaría es poder invitarlos a todos ustedes a que vengan al campamento.
Aunque sea brevemente y en forma virtual.
Así que les voy a pedir que se imaginen que ustedes tienen 15, 16, 17 años,
y yo estoy acá para decirles que efectivamente han sido seleccionados,
sus solicitudes han sido evaluadas, y todos ustedes vienen al campamento, ¿ok?
Es más, a los que pidieron beca de ayuda económica,
¡buenas noticias!, tenemos los fondos.
Vienen todos con nosotros.
Nos vamos a subir a un ómnibus gigantezco, en realidad,
que nos va a llevar por 22 horas a un viaje larguísimo hasta la Patagonia argentina.
Y cuando lleguen a la Patagonia, se van a encontrar con dos cosas.
Primero con un paisaje que los va a llenar de preguntas.
¿Qué hay del otro lado del lago?
¿Cómo se ve el mundo desde la cima de la montaña?
¿Qué nos vamos a encontrar en lo profundo del bosque?
Y por otro lado, a sus compañeros de ruta,
que a pesar de que hace 22 horas que ustedes vienen parloteando con ellos,
siguen siendo perfectos desconocidos.
Vienen de provincias distintas, de ciudades distintas, de pueblos distintos,
de realidades muy distintas a la de ustedes.
Y estas dos cosas combinadas:
los compañeros de ruta, y el paisaje,
les van a dar a ustedes la fuerte sensación de que todo está por descubrirse.
Claro, si uno sube la montaña, o digamos,
corre una rama y se encuentra con un paraje verde donde no hay nadie,
es inevitable la sensación de que uno es un explorador
que está descubriendo esas tierras por primera vez.
Que uno es Charles Darwin en las costas patagónicas.
Y esto es exactamente lo que queremos
que nuestros expedicionarios sientan frente a las actividades científicas
que son las actividades centrales del campamento.
Queremos que se puedan poner en los zapatos de Charles Darwin,
en los de Lavoisier, en los de Newton, en los de Galileo.
Que puedan ver el mundo con los ojos de quien lo vio por primera vez.
Para lograr esto,
tenemos que dejar de lado las clases magistrales y enciclopédicas,
tenemos que abandonar las respuestas que buscan preguntas,
y concentrarnos simplemente en las preguntas que buscan respuestas.
Tenemos que darle la oportunidad a estos chicos
de que se enfrentan a los mismos problemas fundamentales
a los cuales se enfrentaron los científicos originales.
Que puedan hacerse las mismas preguntas,
o por ahí preguntas nuevas que se les ocurren a ellos.
Que puedan idear hipótesis sobre lo que está ocurriendo.
Que se imaginen experimentos para poner a prueba lo que están pensando.
En definitiva, darles la oportunidad de que hagan ciencia.
Bueno, estas oportunidades abundan en el campamento.
Hacemos actividades de física, de química, de biología, de cosas inclasificables.
Yo quiero compartir con ustedes brevemente, dos de esas oportunidades.
En la primera oportunidad, nosotros les pedimos a los chicos
que se pongan en la mente de Lavoisier, el padre de la química,
quien se enfrentó al siguiente problema:
Él observó que hay ciertos materiales, como los metales,
que aumentan de peso cuando se queman,
y como él, nuestros chicos se preguntan:
¿qué? ¿de dónde viene ese peso extra?
¿viene del fuego? ¿viene del aire?
Y si viene del aire, ¿cómo puedo hacer para poner a prueba ésto?
Bueno esta actividad es el inicio de una serie de experimentos
imaginados y reales que los chicos, de verdad, hacen ahí con nosotros,
y que culminan en la dilucidación de dos de los problemas fundamentales
de la historia de la ciencia, que son:
¿De qué está hecho el aire? Y ¿qué pasa cuando las cosas se queman?
Y como ven, estos chicos se hacen preguntas,
formulan hipótesis, diseñan experimentos,
todas herramientas del pensamiento científico
que están desarrollando ahí junto con nosotros.
En la otra oportunidad que quería mencionar,
nosotros les pedimos a los chicos que se pongan
en los zapatos de los antiguos griegos
que querían dilucidar cómo se mueven los astros en el firmamento.
Les asignamos dos o tres estrellas a cada uno,
les damos instrumentos para que vean cómo se mueven el el lapso de 10 minutos.
Y después juntamos todos los datos que ellos tienen,
e improvisamos un mapa del cielo
pegoteando papeles en las paredes y en los techos de una sala.
Cada estrella está representada por un punto, y su movimiento por una flecha.
Los chicos tienen que sentarse ahí, mirar los datos, una y otra vez
y tratar de darse cuenta qué está pasando.
No es fácil.
Miran, discuten, vuelven a mirar.
Finalmente se dan cuenta que todas las estrellas se mueven como si girasen
en torno a un punto en el cual no hay nada.
Y esto no es nada trivial.
Imagínense la satisfacción de un adolescente,
que se dió cuenta cómo se mueve el mundo
con sus propias observaciones, y sus propias mediciones.
Bueno, tal vez estamos pensando alguna actividad
para convencerlos de que el firmamento no es el que se mueve,
sino que es la tierra la que gira alrededor de su eje.
Pero bueno, eso es para futuros campamentos.
Uno se preguntará:
¿Aprenden a pensar científicamente los chicos,
conviviendo durante 10 días con investigadores?
La respuesta es que probablemente no del todo.
Pero adquieren algunas herramientas del pensamiento científico.
Aprenden, por ejemplo, que las ideas científicas no flotan en el aire,
ni crecen en los árboles.
Sino que tienen que ser desarrolladas con mucho cuidado
a partir de la experimentación y de la observación.
Aprenden a distinguir entre un argumento sólido,
y uno que tiene agüjeros lógicos o que carece de evidencia.
Aprenden a desconfiar de las palabras difíciles
y de los argumentos rebuscados,
y a confiar más en su propia capacidad de razonar y resolver situaciones y problemas.
Pero bueno, como en toda exploración,
quizá lo más importante no es a dónde llegamos
sino el hecho de que estamos explorando territorios nuevos.
Hasta ahora les hablé de esta experiencia que es el campamento,
porque acá es donde en Expedición Ciencia desarrollamos
nuestras ideas, y ahí crecen.
Pero obviamente, si nosotros queremos que la mayor parte de la gente piense científicamente,
tenemos que hablar de otra escala,
y tenemos que poder atacar el aula,
y el sistema educativo.
Las buenas noticias es que hemos empezado en ese trayecto,
que nuestras ideas están llegando al aula
a través de campamentos científicos,
a través de libros y artículos que hemos publicado en revistas,
a través de cursos de posgrado,
a través de capacitaciones docentes.
Pero el camino es largo, y el desafío es realmente gigantezco.
Nos preguntarán cuál es el gran sueño en Expedición Ciencia,
y quizá alguno de ustedes piense que
nuestro sueño es lograr que todo aquel que tenga culebrilla diga:
"¡No, jamás iré a un curandero! ¡Nunca, nunca a un curandero!"
Les aclaramos que no; ésto no es lo que queremos.
Lo que queremos es que si alguno tiene culebrilla,
diga: ¡Ésto es una oportunidad buenísima!"
"Si consigo 200 personas más con culebrilla,
puedo hacer un experimento genial."
"Tengo el grupo experimental, tengo el grupo control; ¡nada me detiene!"
No, en serio sí tenemos un sueño en Expedición Ciencia
y es lograr que la gente pueda apreciar.
Porque verdaderamente lo entiende:
Que la ciencia es una de las grandes obras de la humanidad.
Y no solamente porque nos cura de enfermedades,
nos lleva a la Luna,
porque es un instrumento buenísimo para resolver problemas del día a día,
sino porque las ideas que produce
y las formas que tiene de generar estas ideas
son de un ingenio, una profundidad,
y de una belleza formidables.
Queremos que frente a una idea alguien pueda decir:
"¡Wow! ¡Qué experimento!
¿Cómo se le pudo haber ocurrido a alguien una cosa así?"
Si este sueño les parece improbable o extraño,
comparto con ustedes lo que aprendí de estos adolescentes
después de todos estos años:
que pasan cosas extrañas,
pasan cosas maravillosas si uno deja que pasen.
Gracias.